I'm going to start with our directors at
the back you if that's okay and antonin
Jill you guys you guys seem like action
geeks action lovers but what comes
across is that your action has to it has
to have a story there has to be a story
even in set pieces there's kind of so
much going on kind of within things that
you watch would you agree with that and
can you elaborate on but this particular
fur to ourselves as action fetishist
that's right ah yeah no for us that you
know action is like you know it's it's
the it's it's a it's of a piece with all
the rest of the storytelling that we do
it has to be a strong expression of
narrative and character at every moment
that's how we find our way through
action and you know it's like this movie
we had such an amazing cast so many
great characters all the action
sequences are designed around how we're
pushing those characters through the
movie on a storytelling level joining
back to that yeah yes yes it's like amp
said every every every piece of action
the movie either has to define character
and move story forward or it's vacuous
action and I think an audience can only
handle about 30 seconds of that before
they start to get tired of it so we
really put a lot of thought and effort
into it it's also great making these
films because action really is an
integral component of it it really does
help us to find the characters in a very
dynamic way before I threw out to the
huge audience stay a quick question for
our two gents in the middle if that's
okay and staging I'll start with you if
that's okay one words to describe
Captain America please just one more
that was quickly scarce oh yeah one word
to describe Captain America what what
for you to describe our mind and our
minds describe oh um charismatic well
that account what do you got turn my mic
up thank you
rad ass I don't know let's open the
questions after audience i'ma gonna head
to jewel come on ro who is from a
wonderful organization called in to film
who's going to have the first question
Joe 17 years old and a big Marvel fan
and I just like to say I thought the
film was brilliant and thank you for it
my question is for Robert Downey jr. and
you spend a fair bit of time in the film
Mountain costume or what as a civilian
what difference does this make in
maintaining your superhero persona well
I mean III remember from the beginning
trying to establish all all the Marvel
characters I mean for the most part is
you know how do you humanize them or
make them relatable you know I mean and
it's I mean I can only relate to someone
so often when they're all gussied up so
I figure you know but it was a great
opportunity
I'm not really here yet and there's a
lot of people here I just all turn
around for about a half an hour until
I'm back in my body
excellent question by the way what was
it and just next to George or if you
want to pass the mic that'd be great
thank you oh that's Chris so civil wars
possibly want the most political
superhero movies that's kind of ever
happened now and it focuses on quite a
few real world issues as well as kind of
just fingers within the world of the
superhero world um but of course we live
in a pretty complicated world ourselves
I mean the questions I suppose mainly
for Kevin by anyone else about the
opinions I feel free to chime in I mean
if you could choose one superhero to be
in all well to try and help our problems
what would it be
mmm in real life yeah what's - here I
gotta tear this a great question we
usually get what's your favorite
superpower what superpower they want
that's not a good question alone oh it's
coming gosh which superhero in real life
- that's a tough one it isn't just tough
it's a tough one it's not that time
made a vision that answer I'm just so
pretty from when he's omnipotent and he
could pick up the hammer I mean come on
but when he talks everybody turns off
their hearing aids
somebody wants I think if there were
leaders that had you know such such
morals as both Tony and Kat we'd be in
it we'd be in a pretty good place no I
don't like that answer I want as a Kevin
so said one I I nominate Hawkeye cuz he
retires every ten minutes yeah how
stressful it is is a little stressful
going to a barbecue okay next question
in a second or if you want to pawn the
mic just behind you that'd be great
thanks hello there film's amazing by the
way my kids loved it it's this is
question from why eight year old son
Khan for Captain America Iron Man the
film is about Captain America and I'm a
falling out yeah have you two ever
fallen out over something silly on set
and what was it about oh god no not at
all that's one of the best things about
these movies they really somehow
manufacture an environment that I can't
imagine arguing with any person on this
set and you know listen sometimes that
happens on film sets and for some reason
when you step on a Marvel film set it's
just it's like summer camp it really is
like you can't even construct a world
where there would be some sort of
friction and even as they grow the
universe every new person they add to
the fray never no one ever is out of
place they always fit right in and feel
like they've been there for years
speak for yourself here's a way to say
when my son extint started wearing
entirely Captain America PJs and hats
and everything I felt the natural
resentment but being a consummate
professional I didn't bring it into the
workplace a gentleman in the front row
here please thank you we've got one
microphone really
hello this is for Emily Emily hello my
name's mark do you think your character
is looking forward to a further romance
with Steve Rogers or does your character
think is a little bit icky because he
had the hots for your auntie all right I
just was the first British question
we've got um well in the comic books
they actually went on to have a very
interesting complicated love affair so
that was something I loved about you
know when I was doing the research for
Sharon but I don't know how far we'll go
with that we'll see I suppose I mean
it's it helps that it's like the great
aunt it's not you know there's like one
generation I guess I get it some people
think it's weird little icky it's like
sure little icky feel a bit
Emily was it great to see your character
you kind of get up get in and get dirty
with us in terms of get some art you
know get involved in the action in this
yeah yeah we'll see it was so fun I mean
Sharon is a badass in the comic books it
was nice to be able to kind of play with
that a little bit and yes these movies
are great fun to make so happy to be a
part of it right next question
let's go to the lady there with it
awesome here hi my questions for Paul um
Lisa which switch what oh yeah oh my own
tell
awkward and mr. Owen is the goddamn
question Paul Rudd yes all right we saw
you a little bit with Falcon in unmanned
and and I was of sea laundry this is
your first time with everyone and I
wonder if that was a bit of a sort of
initiation or anything like that to sort
of get you it's a part of the group it
was it was there any sort of horrible
noogie ideas everything
yeah like it no everybody was very nice
and very welcoming and you know it was a
bit surreal to see everybody in their
suits and no it was it was a very very
welcoming feeling I've this reference
will just drop like a lead balloon but I
felt a little bit like cousin Oliver
coming along and joining the rest of the
Brady Bunch
thank you very much that's real good
stuff Bethany would you like to comment
on that comment yeah why don't you two
just get a room you know why don't you
marry a Paul G Paul there's a couple of
scenes a particular that feel I don't
know if it's right or not but it felt
like it was it felt like a real
injection of your humor in those scenes
in terms of the scripts and stuff were
you allowed much freedom with you know
ad-lib and improvising and things like
that was very much stick to the script
alright yeah I think I was although most
of stuff is written but there's you know
these guys were definitely saying go
ahead and play around with a little bit
I mean that's part of the fun of a
character like Scott Lang you know even
Roberts saying that you want these
people to be relatable this is a guy
that doesn't was not born with any kind
of super ability and so it's fun to kind
of see meeting these characters through
Scott Lang's eyes and that that's kind
of the way that I felt just being there
shooting that scene it was you know very
little acting required I think of that
part okay next question
gentlemen Garrity signed up and if we
get a microphone to the gentlemen there
as well make you just flip to that
question straight after they are right
in front of you
next time I want all of your body might
hi this is to end with what so in the
surname should we interpret the
recruitment of spider-man by Tony Stark
as him using child soldiers and if so
what's it say to it on one's character a
bit heavy you know it's perhaps the most
powerful child soldier in the world yeah
he's um look there's a certain
narcissism to the character and you know
Tony doesn't want to lose this fight at
the same time I think he also sees a
Spider Man as the greatest living
non-lethal weapon
if you're going out to capture a bunch
of people who you don't necessarily want
to hurt you couldn't ask for a better
character than spider-man to take with
you he does show up and and and you know
illustrate that spider-man he knows how
powerful he is in a video where we see
spider-man stopping a car moving 40
miles an hour where he catches it and
puts it back on the ground so I think he
believes that he's taking with him
perhaps one of the most powerful
characters in the Marvel Universe and I
think he feels like the kid will be well
protected under his tutelage you also
find out in that sequence when things go
wrong the kid says what do I do
and Tony says keep your distance Web
them up so he's already he's he's
obviously mentored the kid for what's
about to go down but it's still very
irresponsible and what what can you a
little bit about about working with Tom
because that scene in particular where
you arrive at his house in his bedroom
so it's wonderful and just about how you
first met on what that meeting was like
an ending cast
well now that two out of three Spider
Men are English I really I really got to
talk with Maguire were off the ledge now
but mr. Hollin anyone who experienced
him you know he's uh he's not a work in
progress I mean he's really something
else and I think by the way folks
reacted to this I mean it's always you
know it's a good
to anyone you know I think he really
came on with a with a bang and there's a
lot of excitement about seeing what'll
happen when he kind of holds its own you
know but uh did anybody no one did
anyone dislike Holland or we all look
David we'll talk about it later
yeah we'll post something if there's any
dissension I think Jenna's got
microphone over there
um my name is Arthur I'm from Germany I
have a question for Daniel uh yes I
really loved the performance I thought
you are villain was one of the most
sympathetic one that Marvel has put out
so far and his motivation is very
understandable like that he's still
alive at the end of the film so I wanted
to ask you are you under contract for
more food question for Kevin then uh I
couldn't answer that question I hope so
but no I mean this is not something I
can I thank you talked about into the
quick answer I hope so but no but I can
you wanted to elaborate on about your
car to be in being sympathetic the most
pathetic villain that's what attracted
me right away because it's not a cliche
stereotyped villain you know he has this
very human motivations he has his
reasons so that gives that gives the
character you know that fence you know
makes him ambivalent X question please a
good mic from there we go
a question for Elizabeth and Emily when
you're on set with this much
testosterone do you kind of dig your
heels in and go really girly or you just
throw in the towel and become bloated
fried Loki fur
I rather just hold my own without having
to be extra girly or blow cough I yet
yeah I think just like hanging as your
self is good I almost made it by the way
without having to say anything
shots that's why I'm here I'd relate the
same to you yeah no I mean it's a lot of
it's a lot of dudes I will say that but
yeah everyone's everyone's great it's
it's a really good environment I don't
think there's any girl flying or blood
flying they kind of watch that language
when they're around you know oh I'm
looking I'm still trying to work on
watching my own yeah exactly
they're not eight by the way as well I
know I do car I understand and look like
can I ask you about one thing that I
love about this is the parents of the
relationships whether those are you know
the allies or or indeed the kind of
conflicts that you have between all the
Marvel kind of superheroes and for you
and Paul's character in particular this
is wonderful kind of play you know off
each other was that fun to kind of to
work with Paul in person if the frustum
will talk to you in a second pause
that's okay bad Paul can you just hold
on one second and but yet working on
those that kind of pattern in the
relationship particularly with I think
it's something that um that fans have
wanted but we're just trying to route it
into something that's like more pure of
a of a of a friend and a companion
because they they we have to make up
like what liket I'm eight I am made from
I'm a mutant I'm made from his stone
basically and so we have that in common
and to use that as a thread that roots
our relationship I think is really
important and grounding in a way Paul
Bettany what she said Bob Rudd take this
one I think they're both they're joined
by the fact that they don't neither of
them know the extent of their powers and
that's that's terrifying but also unites
them and for you being there as a
physical being
well how much fun was that to you know
for the whole entirety of the film oh
it's hot thank you
was it was it was it makeup it wasn't a
mask it wasn't kind of you can disappear
it on you but it was it's makeup that
they then they continue on with
computer-generated stuff so I'm
wondering
every time I laugh and blowing up my
life oh thanks you want a handout
she'll give you a handout you can stop
it shine I'll just stop like that
whisper and you want to finish the
answer to that I was thank you okay
gentlemen in the check check please can
we get microphones in please and then if
someone over this week but at hand I've
will get a microphone to use well lady
in the pink top I think
yeah oh thanks I haven't seen the film
yet so no spoilers please
this is a question for Anthony and
Jeremy as the guys who have the lacking
of superpowers but a whole lot of
weaponry at your side how do you feel
your characters contribute to to the the
overall war that's less than civil a lot
of leg workouts I have it in my contract
that I have two behind shots twice in
the movie so you know thighs and quads
man thousand almost like we answered a
different question I gotta give them
what they want baby you know I can't
have a tree without the trunk you know
what I'm saying called some thighs the
same thing yeah no no no two different
must all go to different muscles on
either side of your leg your hand
problems in the back leads down they are
on the or thought they are they are on
yeah yeah so corn silos no no your
thighs are here your quad is the frontal
salutes last question would you like to
have my quad anybody here watch three
Renner oh brother I love you guys I love
you guys you want to add to that sir
what know about my blood no I will move
on to the next question
I do with a microphone there hi Tina
from the Sun it's one for Roberts and
for Chris has the emergence of the
Justice League whereas it has enough
okay oh there and sorry
Weston was has the emergence of the
Justice League by The Avengers up their
game well III don't think anyone up here
you know makes movies based on what
other people are doing I think you know
for the most part we're kind of doing
what we do because it's it's you know
it's it's really we're really well we do
it's true I shouldn't say we it really
is the the Marvel you know the
higher-ups oops who somehow figured out
this formula of good movies listen when
they get a Bucky will start talking I
was just about to ask you a questions
first oh good I was hoping I want to ask
about the ears about your quads uh not
about your pores ya know about the
airport scene because it's it's a huge
scene er there's there's kind of so much
going on in terms of the actual reality
of film in that how much was there when
you were filming it and kind of how was
it well always half of us were there as
in the team cap because I hear team
irony was a liar hey you know that's all
thanks welcome dude um no it's what we
spent over five months oh is that one
Scene yeah yeah it was sort of chopped
up in different bits and most of the
time it's like what Anthony likes to
describe acting with a tennis ball
because you're just you know there with
your imagination in the green screen the
relationship between between you and
carpets you know he he saw his spoiler
and because your ears for a second
anyone else has not seen it I haven't
seen it okay when Steve loses Peggy look
he's he's only in connection to his
previous life he's he's the thing that
he wants to hold dear that he which is a
real kind of tenderness to this you know
kind of superhero film really which you
guys just play was that something you
kind of you know talked about in terms
of that relationship what it would have
been like in the past
you're bringing it's not yeah that's
that's one of the best parts of the
movie in my opinion that I think you
have these guys who you know they shared
a battlefield together I think any guy
you know it's been in war will tell you
that once you actually risk your life
and I've seen war with someone else
that's your brother for life and they
were brothers even before that and then
given the fact they both have gone
through
such trauma you know cap they've each
lost they've each lost you know and
Bucky more so than me things were taken
from him but as a result we both kind of
have even more of a connection and more
of a bond and and and we are the only
remaining thing especially I don't want
to smell spoilers the the last remaining
chapter the last remaining elements of a
previous life so it really kind of
transcends that kind of family dynamic
that we've you know built in in the
Avengers where you see a guy like cap
who typically does what people need and
in this movie he does kind of what he
wants and he prioritizes his personal
ties over the needs of the masses and
it's all because of this kind of
Brotherhood foundation they've built
right thank you and gentlemen here with
a question and then if we get a
microphone over there as well it's a
question for Robert on behalf of the
male members of the cast and for
Elizabeth on behalf of the female
members of the cast how do you see the
characters progressing through the
movies and how much of that evolution is
down to you as actors as opposed to
what's on the page I don't really want
to talk for anyone else oh here's all I
want to say
Feige and I were out to dinner last
night and you'd have thought they'd
dosed our bubby water we were looking
back at the last 10 years and all the
kind of little miracles and the blood
sweat and tears that had to happen to
keep developing all these character he's
just got kind of like not in a self
aggrandizing way but just kind of gideon
kind of super super grateful at how
things have gotten but as far as the
people who really have to hash it all
out i mean you have to talk to Kevin and
the team I want to say because I
generally give no credit to writers and
I'll try not to do this again that
Markus and McFeely did an exceptional
job on this which is a really tall order
Varys said it
a lady down the front there and then
we'll get her who on this side hello
I don't really mind who answers this but
I just wanted to know did everyone end
up on the team they wanted to be on did
they get the script to go ah I did kind
of want to be on team and there's a
similar question as you come in from
we're streaming online and we've had a
question come in on social media from
Phoebe who wants to know if you could
switch powers with another Avenger at
which one would it be
um that's a good one III mean switching
powers I'd take vision not switching
makeup oh it's a real nightmare but but
the ability alone yeah you can't you
can't beat vision he has an infinity
star in his head I don't know how you
top that Paul would you want to swap
with anymore just stay here you are
yeah I'm okay where I am mm yeah I mean
it might be nice to be Iron Man now and
again yeah but I'm pretty good bro
Thank You Jeremy what okay I'm sure I
don't give you all right so that's
supporting a very high man yeah I've
always thought spider-man oh oh do this
on you get at it great stop and okay
next question
Jenny's got a mic a little bit get out
of here go on ask your question is that
this question Robert so I've seen the
other Avengers films you'll kind of
cuddly and nice to everyone
yeah but there are you yeah and so what
do you prefer being like horrible to
Steve or not acting words obviously I
mean it really just depends on you know
what's the what's the narrative of the
movie as you can see I'm a I'm a worker
amongst war
and I like I like getting in where I fit
in in any movie where I can spend
weekends with Renner
he's Lord of the underworld this is
Pluto back here gonna get you home in
one piece but you're actually finally
going to have a good time
I've got microphone here as well go for
it hi this is Kevin I'm when are we
gonna get our Falcon Bucky roadtrip
movie yeah that's a good idea we're
doing like we're shooting a weekend at
Bernie's spin oh yeah with the three of
us who's the Dead Guy
Jerry Bernie
Bucky's weekend at bucket that's what
we're doing you know bucket Kevin I want
to ask you about the the kind of the
additional characters that brought in to
the Senators we see new characters kind
of coming in to join the teams how do
you know when in the process of putting
that idea together and who was coming in
and where they were going to be how did
you want that it's a kind of like a
chessboard is it know that well the
chessboard on this movie was who who
sided with who to your earlier question
sort of and there were a lot of
characters that went back and forth for
a while before we landed on on the on
the makeup of the team but in terms of
the addition of Tom Hollander spider-man
and chadwick boseman who who couldn't be
here today but who was unbelievably
awesome it's got like Panther it came
from the story we didn't sit down and go
okay we want to introduce these
characters because we want to make more
movies and how do we wedge them in it it
was we are telling civil war we have cap
side we have Tony side and we wanted to
bring in somebody who wasn't allied with
either side and black panther in the
comics is great because he doesn't
really give a [ __ ] about either of the
other of the other side's he has his own
agenda and it was I don't know if the
quarter the way through the development
process where we thought this would be
the time to bring in panther good next
question please gentlemen over there
please we got Mike and so anyone this
side as well for your hand up okay and
the gentlemen there if we get Mike to
I have a question for Kevin John Anthony
what are Nick Fury and Maria hill doing
during the events of civil war you'll
find out soon that's the answer there is
there is story around where they are but
it's story that's coming down the road
future movies sort of fare okay and
there you go you got microphone
girlfriend uh yeah a special B Kevin I
was just wondering how early in the
whole MCU process did super war come
about was it you know pre phase one was
it after Winter Soldier when it was it
actually a Rihanna Ethier it was before
yeah before the MCU even existed in the
early days of I think we were even just
beginning to dream about maybe becoming
our studio and getting financing was
about a little over ten years ago which
is when Civil War was published and and
it was an amazing comic series and I
remember reading it you know every month
when when it came out in thinking it was
probably be impossible but would it be
cool someday to do this and it wasn't
until about two years ago two and a half
years ago that we thought now is the
time we've assembled enough players that
we could do it then can I ask a question
for me how do you decide who stands
going to be whose family what Heidi do
in each phone who decides where he's
going to pop up and it's very sometimes
the idea comes about very early and is
incorporated into the script and
sometimes based on his schedule or where
he's where he is willing to travel it
comes about sort of later in the process
on guardians of the galaxy it was uh it
was shot later and I think this one was
shot during production but I remember
when the idea came up for this one was
in the draft I think it was in the draft
yeah yeah I usually would comb through
when the script is done and try to find
a spot for stamp yeah okay next question
there's a lady at the back in a blue
shark and get your microphone and anyone
else on this side where's your
Hollifield question I'll get my you've
had one you can if there's time you can
have another one but they'll gentleman
behind it
hi really it's a question focus Evans so
there's this time around like models
that Marvel Universe is really like
stepped up so like what were your
initial thoughts when you first read the
script the Civil War uh it was it was
exciting you know I mean a lot of it
rested on down his shoulders whether or
not that he would be willing to do this
you know and and you know right away
that when you bring Downey into the
equation the movie is gonna you know
it's it's gonna have a certain level of
awareness and it's gonna have a certain
level of charisma he just he'd be you
know that that's what he comes with and
it was it was it was exciting it was
exciting to think that you could kind of
you knew what it meant as a jump-off you
knew what that meant
because obviously the civil one the
comic books incorporates so many
characters and at the end of the movie
you know Marvel has this great history
of never leaving you completely
satisfied you kind of anticipate the the
next chapter and this would obviously
leave the entire MCU and a little bit of
disarray which is exciting because it's
only going to be more rich for the next
Avengers film so for me I was I was
thrilled I mean [ __ ] I'll take all the
help I can get gentlemen their question
hi this is a question for Chris again
and where are you there yeah yeah
following the film last week a lot my
friends who saw it at the same time one
of the things they were talking about
was that scene where you pulled down a
helicopter I don't know the shape of
your arms yeah little bit of bicep power
insane teasing both and was it more than
vagina how what was it how hard is it
supervisor I missed it
how hard is it to look like much oh I
don't think it was Kevin did you know
that's alright I think I think it was me
but it's you know you do those things
luckily between scheduling and Russa
everyone you try and get those scenes as
early on and in filming as possible
because you you gradually shed weight as
you're filming you wear in that suit
every day and you just I was helping him
work on his shoulder about six weeks
after that I I really genuinely did mess
up something in my armor we love that
shot doing it you know
it's very unnatural position to be in
and you like luck you're trying to flex
you're trying to look good on that like
you know madness it's not a utilitarian
shot you it's really just trying to look
good that come on in I was just dumb
what do you want I was eight um you
really were holding back a helicopter
too it was on a rig clearly but the
first take we did rig it it didn't go
far enough and so you're kind of just
you look silly almost and you say guys
you got a can we get it so it actually
extends to the point what you really are
trying to hold something and they did
and you really do all of a sudden you
are trying to hold something may not be
a helicopter but regardless it it did
something and that's true they were they
were many days that I would come into
Downey's trailer and he has all these
amazing contraptions he's like well I
was gonna say another comic book
character we don't want to bring DC into
this but he has all these amazing toys
and uh and and he really had all these
little will you know stickers and weird
things and like electro medicine
whatever it is and it actually was great
it's a mess again though I'll mention
this I remember the day we shot that
scene there was a miscommunication with
the costume department and Chris came
the set to start the scene in a jacket
and Joe and I were like no no no no it
would've been a different scene yeah and
jacket.look onset physio mr. Don junior
like that no sight closer that's nice
you Robert thanks Jeremy rubbing down
Chris that's sweet little digital
stimulation never have anybody we're
talking too much we really owe each
other I get along gentleman there with
the beard bro question and then but I
have a questions you're an intermission
in this press conference do you want to
go no no I'm fine you want to go
answered a lot götze question of rollin
yeah if superheroes were a reality in
2016 what do you think the government's
reaction to them will be teamironman hey
would there would have to be some sort
of responsibility you have to answer to
somebody that you you couldn't just let
these group of vigilantes answer to
themselves right I mean that'sthat's the
sad truth I mean the truth is of this if
it really were Avengers I would be team
Iron Man I would I mean what god you're
here I was really having a hard time
grasping that concept yeah and then last
question to the met Jenna just behind
there
yeah you got a mic yeah the next
question is for rather than alter Paul
Daniel with his German few I would be
interested who is at the movie said the
big boss who has got the biggest trailer
and Wow
it wasn't mine I think it's Matthews
that would be correct continent where
did the biggest trailer uh well I have a
lot of stuff you know so I just you know
it it's really nice just really you know
I got a you know yeah like five bubble
yeah what you gotta fit the time I got
off at them thighs and quads so yeah
right you know but he guys like five
five of them yeah where Robert actually
has a smallest trailer he just has
another four trailers right this
beautiful Airstream trailer again
there's there's actually the state of
Georgia want to give it its own zip code
it's like a kiddie choo-choo train and
it just goes around it
Circle and what's about you trailer go
train I didn't get one no but we're
maybe you got a chair you have really
come back from Germany I remember that
the first day the first scene I had with
with Robert after five minutes he asked
me if I had allergies I didn't
understand the question and when I had
lunch and was eating my burrito in my
humble little trailer somebody knocked
at my door and said and he was sitting
in the Gulf Kenny he said like you're
cordially invited to Robert Downey's
Village my burrito and then in the far
distance I saw that huge space with yeah
four or five
Tyler's you know thank you long poetry's
I had a three-course meal right did you
get my and I always quite said when he
left because I was at the invited price
that's everybody's goal every day is
that lunch to see who's gonna get
invited to the villa and you get so
jealous like the day he was invited I
see him gone I'm like I'm not a Brandon
Carter of the mg you probably introduced
me to quinoa I was like what is this
beautiful grain a lot of marbles I'm
putting in my mouth like that's keen now
where do I buy that he had a good one I
I wanted to have Sebastian over sooner
but he sent me this video of him just
ripping out my sub pearls with a
decapitated Iron Man just all of that
thing and I was like this guy's method
that's now it's find out what his
allergies are and it's time for
intermission I'm afraid and thank you
very much indeed for you time your
questions and
you